Late last year, Alibaba Co-founder Jack Ma
was confirmed as an official member of the
Chinese Communist Party.
Jack Ma also happens to have a not-very-communist-sounding
estimated net worth that peaked at $50 billion
dollars in 2018.
Even though China remains officially committed
to a communist future – with equality for
all and wealth distribution based on need
– its history of capitalistic compromise
has made it *the* place to turn personal millions
in billions.
This is your Bloomberg QuickTake on China’s
Billionaires.
By one estimate, China creates a new billionaire
every two days.
The seeds of the billionaire boom were planted
four decades ago, beginning in 1978, when
communist party patriarch Deng Xiaoping opened
the country up to private enterprise and investment.
Since then, China began shifting away from
agriculture, and increased its focus on manufacturing,
eventually leading to growth that turned the
country into the world’s second-largest
economy, behind the U.S.
There's been this discussion of what is socialism,
what is capitalism, and Deng just kind of
said, "What they're not is, they're not poverty."
The lines between business and politics have
become increasingly hazy as President Xi Jinping
has led a campaign to ensure the communist
party plays a leading role in all aspects
of society.
the internet companies have been really this
sort of shining example of what China hopes
it can become, which is cutting edge, smart
people doing cool things, and making products
that people around the world want to use.
I think they're a lot less enthused with massive
amounts of private wealth that that often
creates.
But China hasn’t given up on Communism,
it just made full communism a goal with no
time frame.
On the roadmap to Communism, the country will
have to become fully socialist first, which
Xi has set a goal of reaching by 2035.
China is a communist country, but it's a one-party
state, so in that sense, the communist party
is very intensely focused on making sure it
can maintain control and stability, at the
expense of a lot of civil rights and sort
of other freedoms and liberties that other
countries sort of take for granted sometimes.
Jack Ma was among 100 people honored by the
Communist Party as part of the celebration
marking 40 years of China’s economic reform
- evidence that on the issue of communism,
China is more than content to wait.